when it comes to enjoying lockdown i
don't think anyone seems to have enjoyed
it more
than jamie dornan uh you've had a blast
in
in lockdown haven't you did i
yeah it was fun it wasn't fun all the
time no but i have but like your kids
would come home from school and it was
yeah it sounds like you got it you got
it right yeah they would sort of dress
me up and um
you know i'm i'm you know i'm all for
that you know getting there
putting on a dress not tonight clearly
where were the kids tonight and
but now you posted a picture is this was
it your daughter's seventh birthday
party
it would have been yes now so here's the
picture you've got no
top on at your daughter's seventh
birthday party jamie what is that
picture that's weird
i don't know what a what the reaction we
want here
why is there a blue light coming from
i'll tell you exactly what happened
let me tell you exactly what please do
there's a long time ago now because
november obviously we're not on year's
eve
we all know and um
i have to think way back four days ago
um but we know there was a party for the
five of us the the
the nuclear family and uh
we were all having a party and that's
like a sort of playroom area we have
and there's a disco going on you can see
there's disco lights there in the
background
and we had these balloons that had
lights in them and i had one of those in
my mouth when i was
dancing and i was trying to make my kids
laugh and i
took my shirt off and
i was i was sort of dancing around and
then one of the balloons popped
and i was left with this little blue
light in my thing and i turned around
and none of my family were there
and i was just dancing alone and i was
like i was actually took a picture to
send to my wife going where is everyone
going
and then i decided yeah
wow i know i mean you could be a full-on
rave in that
yeah i know listen it doesn't say
seven-year-olds party
yeah oh i see when jamie dornan does it
everyone's like that's funny when i do
it it's mr kumar please get out of this
school
so jessica are you when are you heading
back to work how long is your holiday
going to be
right now i'm just you know enjoying the
holidays waiting for this vaccine to be
doled out
i'll be first in line jessica just
saying so nice to see you again
uh please come and see us when you when
you can in the flash have a fantastic
2021 jessica chastain everybody
you